nous croyons que les unit à domestique
eésad très tard probablement à l'époque
fait surtout les bonbons sucettes
parce que avant les chats c'étaient les
petits bouchers c'est à dire que les
chats étaient courants alors quid de cet
abri du tout le retenir est bon mais
comme nous les pigeons pouvait pas les
toucher
le chat domestique et du nord sinaï et
le chagrine ise est alors au moyen-âge
loyen le premier chat sacha la bicigui
arrive en europe au concile de mâcon
donc 80 viennent c'est fabuleux sylvie
là je les emmenais en question a mené
femme est alors plus on a apporté le
seul chat soit arrivé à chrétien c est
la fin du gros celle des services de
santé qu'elle ferait mieux
objectif considère que ne pas se montant
à caresser son chat reprend déjà
alors quid des chats l'extraordinaire
histoire de la peste noire quand la
peste noire a été pire que la batterie
puisqu'il inscrit un tir a été arrêté
hier quand même il savait mystère des
mots c'est les chats alors cette fois
c'est courant et d'eau mais c'est et
corrigée qui touche maintenant et on a
mobilisé la flotte du ciel qui pendant
un an n'a pas fait autre chose que de
partir de venise pour arriver à damiette
alexandrie pour la charger le char à
bord est localisée donc recommencer et
on l'a cherché comme un peu les chats en
avance dès et ça a marché
non pas parce qu'ils sont battus mais il
semble que c'est parce que depuis
déménagé de rats au fond la ram a devant
lui quand l'odeur 2000 à savoir les
talons c'est qu'on peut fuir parce que
la paix selon moi quand on ne nous
quitte
elle cherchait peut d'ailleurs français
vous avez jusqu'à la casa le ciel est
alors il retourne par la pologne la
russie et ils sont arrivés en chine par
l'onu les races
chaque été les plus improbables d
inscrire la mort vous rendez vous pour
cette guerre sic ce que ça aurait aidé
dans votre vie alors là vous allez c'est
une question personnelle mais l'échalote
sont apparus en toujours que j'ai
toujours aimé et mais je crois qu'il ya
les gens qui aiment les chats dont
l'exemple illustre d'honneur c'est
qu'ils ont continué ce genre de
plaisanterie c'est bien on tombe de
toutankhamon les rats ne sais pas mais
n'avait pas franchi la porte du tour
avant les âmes se sont malgré les
valeurs ce sont les hommes qui ont
permis aux rats de rentrée alors dire à
ce chantre aperçu que le jaune dont vous
fait du personnage dans les fresques
c'est très bon et alors ils se sont mis
à gratter tout ce qu'ils ont plus
attachés sur ses patins ou encore blood
ça tout ce qu'ils ont pu des pieds des
personnages parce que les personnages
dangereux ils sont sur un fond bleu ou
vert alors ça c'est du poignet touche
pas vous arriver maintenant et vous avez
le lait frais couvrent les murs
absolument normal sauf que tous les
types n'ont plus de pied et non plus du
mauvais parce que tout ça est remplacé
par lui c'est grave et les risques ont
tous mangé et il ya des trous dans le
nom mais cieux
si vous voulez cela le plâtre la plus
belle rémi le moment avec une
bibliothèque étendue humeur et nakhal
dont il met en vente à l'hôtel catalogue
alors apollinaire intacte mais ton âge
albert blessés qui pour nous trouver
mais l'amour est qu'elle y trouve des
gens du plus grand talent abstract cèdre
et alors explication très simple
gourmaud ne rangez pas lui sa
bibliothèque alphabétiquement il mettait
à porter ça manque c'est à dire les
livres qui admirait et tout le bas et
s'est fait que les cinq heures alors les
chasseurs et les griffes seul état caire
et quand on a remis ça mais il faut le
dire c'est que je suis maintenant tu es
comme baudelaire un de ses poètes
préférés
andré malraux a toujours eu des rapports
privilégiés avec les champs
et l'intérieur y était jusqu'à la guerre
que azincourt les français avaient été
battus parce que le meilleur va karkwa
pour leur arc
barak avait était détrempé qui n'est pas
pu tirer contre les anglais et les
informations qu'on l'ait depuis la
guerre on donne y intéressent
excessivement amusant qui est que les
anglais avec sa canne anglaise et à
l'époque la seule arme et seuls des
chercheurs mais le métier bon et il
avait des capitaines chat et il avait
déjà bon pour jeu pourquoi quand dira
qu'ils étaient bien noir sont alliées
vers le champ de bataille
ils ont senti le chat et ils sont sales
ils m'ont prêté et ils ont mangé les
corps des arcs
c'est pas du reste du temps je sais pas
ce qu'ils ont mangé et c'est pour ça
qu'ils aient eu des quatre pylônes rich
a jusqu en ce sens que ça en angleterre
on savait plus quoi ça servait et csl
originale de gestion rétabli ce trucage
la revente général de gaulle qui m'a dit
il faudrait d'abord les anglais sur le
penchant très sérieux cran quand on vous
dit
voilà nos sources faut la revoir chiche
en passant lui d'arbalète ça serait bien
qu'il me connaît larme à l'oeil
tout cela pour que ces trois bouts je
crois qu'il avait plein de chiens que
l'on aime on ne voyait pas alors que le
chat gris gris retrouve à un but de
cette partie de la maison est d'ailleurs
le général on parle à purpan avec la
france y est un as quand je lui dis où
en êtes-vous avec les cheveux et qui me
répond ils n'ont pas peur de noir vous
aimez les chats à l'honneur du puy à moi
tes valises à fait les supplie et c'est
celui qui comme uri et complet
minutes 1 donne on est tous des saints
et la nuit
non